turning overseas the united nations says
around 95 percent of people in
afghanistan are going hungry it is one
more sign of that country's economic
collapse after the taliban sees control
following the u.s withdrawal mts tayyip
visited a children's hospital in the
capitol where families are desperate for
help
there are few greater agonies for a
mother than a sick child six-month-old
sophia suffers from severe anemia caused
by acute malnutrition
her mother
says we just didn't have enough money to
feed her
her father baba shireen tells us he's
desperate
what sort of help does your family need
right now
he says i need food i have five kids
they're also hungry
hunger and poverty have long stalked
afghanistan's children but since the
taliban seized power two months ago the
nation is spiraling into a deep
humanitarian crisis
[Applause]
according to the united nations if
urgent humanitarian assistance doesn't
come soon more than a million children
will die from malnutrition
signs of desperation can be seen in
every corner of afghanistan
this usaid funded world food program
distribution center is packed but all
that's on offer are sacks of flour and a
bit of salt wahid ahmed darwesh is one
of the organizers
people come here because they're hungry
they need food but all you're able to
give them is flour and salt
right now
not enough but it has
saved their life
while we were talking the taliban
arrived the taliban make problems every
day as soon as you see
the time this is taliban
and what are they saying
oh they they say stop
filming yeah we should continue later
we overheard one taliban fighter ask his
commander if he should kill us
it was time for our crew to leave
as the group tightens its grip on power
afghanistan is barely holding on the
biden administration has already frozen
nine billion dollars in assets and along
with other nations says any future
financial support is conditional on the
taliban proving it's moderated since it
was last in power
zabihullah majahid is the taliban's
chief spokesman
the united nations is warning over a
million children will die from
malnutrition if nothing urgent is done
can the taliban solve this crisis
without the help of the world and the
united states
he says on the one hand they say a
million children will die but on the
other the u.s are holding our money the
u.s should release our money so we can
save our children
this month world leaders promised 1.2
billion dollars in aid to prevent a
humanitarian catastrophe across
afghanistan but it won't do much to
bring the economy back from the brink
and won't be enough to help the
country's smallest
and most vulnerable
for cbs mornings i'm impiaz tayob in
kabul
mts putting himself in danger to give us
the stories that we need and no matter
where it is a hunger issue is a human
issue